PATRICK WINSTON: I have
extremely bad news.
Halloween falls this
year on a Sunday.
But we in 6.034 refuse to
suffer the slings and arrows
of outrageous fortune.
So we've decided that
Halloween is today,
as far 6.034 is concerned.
Kenny, could you give
me a hand, please?
If you could take that
and put it over there.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]?
PATRICK WINSTON: Mm hm.
Just give it to them.
You can take as much
of this as you like.
The rest will be given to that
herd of stampeding freshman
that comes in after.
It's a cornucopia
of legal drugs.
Chocolate does produce
a kind of mild high,
and I recommend it before
quizzes and giving lectures.
I have a friend of mine, one of
the Nobel laureates in biology,
always eats chocolate
before he lectures.
Gives him a little edge.
Otherwise, he'll be flat.
So I recommend it.
It will take, I
suppose, a little while
to digest that neural net stuff.
A little richer than
usual in mathematics.
So today, we're going to
talk about another effort
at mimicking biology.
This is easy stuff.
It's just conceptual.
And you won't see
this on the next quiz.
But you will see
it on the final.
It's one of those quiz
five type problems,
where I ask you questions to
see if you were here and awake.
So a typical question
might be, Professor Winston
is a creationist, or
something like that.
Not too hard to answer.
In any event, if it's been hard
to develop a real understanding
of intelligence,
occasionally the hope
is that by mimicking biology
or mimicking evolution,
you can circumnavigate
all the problems.
And one of those
kinds of efforts
is ever to imitate evolution.
So we're going to talk
today about so called
genetic algorithms,
which are naive attempts
to mimic naive evolution.
Now, I realize that most MIT
students have a basic grasp
of sexual reproduction.
But I've found in
talking with students
that many times, they're
a little fuzzy on some
of the details.
So let's start off by reflecting
a little bit about how
that works.
So let's see, we
need pink and blue.
And here's our cell,
and here is its nucleus,
and here are mommy and
daddy's chromosomes.
We'll just pretend
there's one pair.
Now ordinarily, in ordinary cell
division, you get two cells.
Both have a nucleus, and the
process of producing them
involves the duplication
of those chromosomes.
And then one pair ends up
in each of the child cells,
and that's all there is to that.
That's mitosis.
But then, when we talk
about reproduction,
it's more complicated
because those chromosomes
get all twisted up, and they
break, and they recombine.
So when we talk about
the cells that split off
from one of these
germ cells, it's
no longer appropriate to
talk about the pink one
and the blue one, because
the pink one and the blue one
are all mixed up.
So you get two chromosomes
here and two here.
But through some miracle
of nature, which has always
amazed me, these two
cells split, in turn,
into four cells altogether.
And each of those four
cells at the bottom
gets one of the
chromosomes that was
produced by the twisting up
of the rope and recombination.
Then, along comes
a special occasion.
And now we can think of this
as being a blue one and this
as being a pink one.
And they come together, and
you get a new person, like so.
Note that your mother
and father's chromosomes
are never, never recombined.
It's your grandparents
chromosomes that recombine.
So that's what it's like.
And the main thing
to note about this
is-- well, a couple things.
If you happen to be female,
this part of the process--
this part over here-- took
place before you were born.
If you happen to be male, it's
going on right now as we speak,
which probably
explains something.
But in any event, it's
going on right now.
But whenever it
goes on, there are
lots of opportunities
for throwing dice.
So God threw all
the dice before you
were born, if you
happen to be a female,
in this part of the
process over here.
Then, of course, more
dice got thrown here
when the decision
was made about which
particular cells got to fuse
to form a new individual.
So I want to beat on this
idea of lots of choice.
When we talk about
genetic algorithms,
and we talk about nature, there
are lots of choices in there.
And that means there
are lots of choices
to intervene, to screw around,
to make things work out
the way you want.
But in any event, there we are.
That's the basic idea, and it
all starts with chromosomes.
So we could think of
implementing something
that imitates that
with the ACTG stuff
that you learned all
about in Seminar 1.
But we're computer scientists.
We don't like Base 4.
We like Base 2.
So I'm going to just suggest
that our chromosomes are binary
in this system that
we're going to build.
So that might be a chromosome.
And it doesn't
have to be binary.
It can be symbolic
for fall I care.
But it's just some
string of things
that determine how the
ultimate system behaves.
So it all starts out, then,
with some of these chromosomes,
some of these
simulated chromosomes,
simulated,
simplified, and naive.
And there's a population
of chromosomes.
The population of
chromosomes-- it
might be subject to a
little bit of mutation.
That is to say, a zero becomes
a one, or a one becomes a zero.
That happens a lot.
That mutation stuff
happens over here
when things get twisted
up and recombined.
There are copying
errors and stuff.
Cosmic rays hit it all the time.
All sorts of reasons
why there might
be a single point of change.
That produces the
mutation effect.
So here, we have a population
that starts off over here.
And some of those things
are subject to mutation.
And you'll note, here's a
whole bunch of choice already.
How many of these mutations
do you allow per chromosome,
for example?
How many of the chromosomes
just slip through
without any mutation?
Those are choices you can make.
Once you've made
those choices, then we
have the crossover phenomenon.
Let's identify one of these
guys as the pink one and one
of these guys as the blue one.
And so now we have the
pink one cruised along
as well as the blue one.
The pink one and the blue
one cross and produce
a new chromosome,
just like in nature.
So we take the front part of
one, back part of the other,
and we fuse them together.
And some may slip by without
any of that, like so.
Well, these things are meant to
be combined in pairs, like so,
but they may not have
any crossover in them.
So you have another
set of choices.
How many crossovers do you
allow per recombination?
You get another set of choices.
So now we've got a population
of modified chromosomes
through mutation and crossover.
So the next thing to do
is we have the genotype
to phenotype transition.
That is to say the chromosome
determines the individual.
It may be a person.
It may be a cow.
It may be a computer program.
I don't care what.
But that code down
there has to be
interpreted to be a something.
So it is the
genotype, and it has
to be interpreted to
be something which
is the phenotype, the thing
that the stuff down there is
encoding for.
So here, we have a
bunch of individuals.
Now, each of those
individuals, because they
have varying
chromosomal composition,
will have a different fitness.
So these fitnesses
might be-- well,
who knows how they
might be scored.
But we're computer scientists.
We might as well use numbers.
So maybe this guy's
fitness is 88,
and this guy's fitness
is 77, and so on.
So now that we've got fitness--
by the way, notice
all the choices
involved there-- choice
of how you interpret
the genotype, choice about
how the phenotype produces
the fitness.
And now we have a choice
about how the fitness produces
a probability, like 0.8
and 0.1, or something
like that--
probability of survival
into the next generation.
So now, once we've got
those probabilities,
we actually have selection.
And those phenotypes out
there produce genotypes,
a new set of
chromosomes, and that
completes our loop that
goes back in there.
And so that's the
new generation.
Sounds simple.
So if you're going to
make this work, of course,
you have a million
choices, as I'm
going to emphasize
over and over again.
And one of your choices
is, for example, how
do you compute the
probability of survival
to the next generation
given the fitness?
So we have to go, somehow,
from numbers like these
to probabilities like those.
So I'm going to talk about
several ways of doing it.
None of them are magic.
None of them was specified
and stipulated by God
as the right way.
But they have increasingly
good properties with respect
to this kind of processing.
So the simplest thing
you can do-- idea number
one for computing
the-- see, what you do
is you get this whole
bag of individuals,
and you have to decide
who's going to survive
to the next generation.
So at each step,
everything in the bank
has a probability of being
the one you pick out and put
in the next generation.
So at any step, the sum
of the probabilities
for each of those guys
is 1, because that's
how high probability works.
The probability of a
complete set, added all up,
is probability of 1.
So one thing you
can do is you can
say that the
probability that you're
going to draw individual
i is equal to,
or maybe is proportional to,
the fitness of that individual.
I haven't completed
the expression,
so it's not a probability
yet, because some piece of it
won't add up to 1.
How can I ensure that
it will add up to 1?
That's easy.
Right.
All I have to do is
divide by the sum
of the fitnesses over i.
So there's a probability
measure that's
produced from the fitnesses.
Yeah.
STUDENT: You need to make
sure that the fitnesses aren't
negative.
PATRICK WINSTON: Have to make
sure the fitnesses are what?
STUDENT: Aren't negative.
PATRICK WINSTON: He
says I have to make
sure the fitnesses
aren't negative.
Yeah, it would be
embarrassing if they were.
So we'll just truncate
anything like that as 0.
You've got a lot of choice how
you can calculate the fitness.
And maybe you will produce
negative numbers, in which case
you have to think a
little bit more about it.
So now, what about an example?
Well, I'm going to
show you an example.
Why don't I show
you the example.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to have a genetic
algorithm that looks
for an optimal value in a space.
And there's the space.
Now, you'll notice it's
a bunch of contour lines,
a bunch of hills in that space.
Let me show you how
that space was produced.
The fitness is a
function of x and y,
and it's equal to the sine of
some constant times x, quantity
squared, times the sine of some
constant y, quantity squared,
e to the plus x plus y
divided by some constant.
So sigma and omega
there are just in there
so that it kind of makes a
nice picture for demonstration.
So there's a space.
And clearly, where you
want to be in this space
is in the upper
right-hand corner.
That's the optimal value.
But we have a genetic algorithm
that doesn't know anything.
All it knows how to do
is mutate and cross over.
So it's going to start off
with a population of 1.
It's a little red dot
down in the lower left.
So here's how it's
going to evolve.
There's going to be s
chromosome consisting
of two numbers, an x
number and a y number,
like, say, 0.3 and 0.7.
Here's another one, which
might be 0.6 and 0.2.
So the mutation
operator is going
to take one of those values
and change it a little bit.
So it might say, well, we'll
take 3, and we'll make it 0.2.
And the crossover
operation is going
to exchange the x and
y values of pairs.
So if we have a
crossover here, then what
we're going to get out
from this one-- well,
we're going to get out a
combination of these two.
And it's going to
look like this.
Because what we're
going to do is we're
going to take the x value of
1 and combine it with the y
value of the other one.
So this is going to be 0.2--
my mutated value and 0.2--
and this is going
to be 0.6 and 0.7.
So that's how my little
genetic algorithm
heck is going to work.
So having coded this up, we
can now see how it flows.
Let's run it 10 generations.
So the population is rapidly
expanded to some fixed limit.
I forgot what it is--
30 or so.
And we can run that
100 generations.
And so this seems to be
getting stuck, kind of, right?
So what's the problem?
The problem is local maxima.
This is fundamentally a
hill climbing mechanism.
Note that I have not included
any crossover so far.
So if I do have
crossover, then if I've
got a good x value
and a good y value,
I can cross them
over and get them
both in the same situation.
But nevertheless,
this thing doesn't
seem to be working very well.
STUDENT: Professor,
I have a question.
PATRICK WINSTON: Yeah.
STUDENT: That picture is
just the contour lines
of that function.
PATRICK WINSTON: The contour
lines of that function.
So the reason you see
a lot of contour lines
in the upper right
is because it gets
much higher because there's that
exponential term that increases
as you go up to the right.
So I don't know, it looks--
let's put some crossover in
and repeat the experience.
We'll run 100 generations.
I don't know.
It just doesn't seem
to be going anywhere.
Sometimes, it'll go right
to the global maximum.
Sometimes it takes a long time.
It's got a random number
generator in there,
so I have no control over it.
So it's going to get there.
I couldn't tell
whether the crossover
was doing any good or not.
Oh, well, here's one.
Let's make this a little
bit more complicated.
Suppose that's the space.
Now it's going to
be in real trouble,
because it'll never
get across that moat.
You know, you would think
that it would climb up
to the x maximum or
to the y maximum,
but it's not going
to do very well.
Even with crossover,
it's just not
going to do very
well, because it's
climbing up those local hills.
Anybody got an idea
about one simple thing
we could do to make
it work better?
Yeah, you could increase
step size, right?
Let me you see if
that will help.
You know, even that
doesn't seem to help.
So we have to conclude--
do we conclude
that this is a bad idea?
Well, we don't have to
conclude it's a bad idea yet,
because we may just look at
it and ask why five times.
And we might ask,
well, maybe we can
get a better mechanism in
there to translate fitness
into probability of survival.
Using this formula is
kind of strange, anyway,
because suppose temperature
is one of your fitness
characteristics.
The hotter, the better.
Then the ratio of
the probability
that you'll survive
versus the person
next to you, that
ratio will depend on
whether you're measuring
the temperature in Celsius
or Fahrenheit, right?
Because you've
shifted the origin
that shifts the
ratio that shifts
the probability of success.
So it seems kind of strange to
just take these things right
straight into probabilities.
So a better idea--
idea number two--
is to say, well,
shoot, maybe we don't
care about what the
actual fitnesses are.
All we really care
about is the rank order
of all the candidates.
So the candidate
with the most fitness
will have the most
probability of getting
into the next generation.
The candidate with the
second most fitness
will have the second highest
probability, and so on.
But we're not going to use the
actual fitnesses themselves
to make the determination.
Instead, what we're going to
do with this mechanism number
two-- this is the
rank space method--
is this.
We're going to say that the
probability of the highest
ranking individual of getting
into the next generation
is some constant P sub c, which,
of course, you can select.
You have another choice.
Then, if that guy
doesn't get selected,
the probability of the second
highest ranking individual
getting in the
next generation is
going to be the probability that
that guy didn't get in there.
That's 1 minus P sub c times
the same probability constant.
And so you can see
how this is going.
P3 will be equal to 1 minus P
sub c squared terms P sub c.
P sub n minus 1
will be equal to 1
minus that probability constant
to the n minus-- n minus 2
times P sub c.
And then there's only
one individual left.
And then if you got
through all these guys
and haven't got
anybody selected,
then you've got to
select the last guy.
And so the probability you're
going to select the last guy
is going to be 1 minus P
sub c to the n minus 1.
So it's a probability
you've missed all those guys
in the first n minus 1 choices.
Yeah, it is, honest to God.
See, this is the probability
that this last guys
is going to get selected.
It's not the
probability that it's
the last guy getting selected,
given that the others haven't
been select.
Trust me, it's right.
Are you thinking
it ought to be 1?
STUDENT: What?
PATRICK WINSTON: Were you
thinking it ought to be 1?
STUDENT: No, I was thinking that
I was wondering why you were re
rolling the dice, so to speak.
PATRICK WINSTON: You
are re rolling the dice.
You've got a
probability each time,
except for the last time, when,
of course, you have to take it.
There's nothing left.
There's no other choice.
STUDENT: I have a question.
PATRICK WINSTON:
Yeah, [? Lunnare ?]..
STUDENT: So when you jump
from P sub 1 to P sub 2,
that makes sense.
P sub 2 to P sub 3 you're
saying that the probability
PATRICK WINSTON:
It's the probability
depends on the
first two choices.
STUDENT: Yeah, but
the second choice
had probability one minus P
sub c times P sub c, not--
PATRICK WINSTON: Think
about it this way.
It's the probability you
didn't choose the first two.
So the probability you
didn't choose the first one
is one minus P sub c.
The probability you didn't
choose the next one, as well,
because you're choosing that
next one with probability P sub
c, it's the square of it.
So that might work better.
Let's give it a shot.
Let's go back to our
original space choice,
and we set and switch to
the rank fitness method.
And we'll run out
100 generations.
Whoa!
What happened there?
That was pretty fast.
Maybe I used a big step size.
Yeah, that's a little
bit more reasonable.
Oops-- what happened?
It's really getting
stuck on a local maximum.
So evidently, I've choosed
a constant P sub c such
that it just drove it
right up the nearest hill.
On the other hand, if I change
the step size a little bit,
maybe I can get
it to spread out.
I sure did.
And now that it's
managed to evolve over
there to find the
maximum value, now I
can clamp down on
the step size again.
And now it shows
no more diversity.
It's just locked on to
that global maximum.
So this is not unlike what
evolution sometimes does.
Sometimes, species
collapse into a state
where they don't change for 500
million or 600 million years,
like sharks, for example.
Sometimes, they only
survive if they've
got a lot of diversity
built into their way of life
so that they can adjust
to habitat changes.
Now, when you increase
the step size,
because you're stuck
on a local maximum,
it's like heating up a metal.
You make everything
kind of vibrate
more, make bigger steps.
So this kind of process, where
you may start with a big step
size and then gradually
reduce the step size,
is called simulated
annealing, because it's
like letting a metal cool down.
So you start off with a
big temperature-- big step
size-- that covers the space.
And then you slowly
reduce the step size,
so you actually crawl
up to the local maxima
that are available.
So that seemed to
work pretty well.
Let's see if we can get
it to work on the harder
problem of the moat.
So it's not doing very well.
Better increase the step size.
No, it's still kind of stuck.
Even though it's got the
capacity to cross over,
it's so stuck on that
lower right hand corner,
it can't get up that vertical
branch to get to a point
where a crossover will
produce a value up there
in the upper right-hand corner.
So we're still not home yet.
So what's the trouble?
The trouble is that the fitness
mechanism is just driving
things up to the local maximum.
It's just terribly unfortunate.
What to do?
Well, here's something
you could do.
You can say, well,
if the problem is
we've lost the diversity
in our population,
then we can measure
the diversity-- not
only the fitness of
the set of individuals
we're selecting from, but we
can measure how different they
are on the individuals
we've already selected
for the next population.
In other words, we can get a
diverse population as well as
a fit population if, when
we make our selection,
we consider not
only their fitness
but how different they are
from the individuals that
have already been selected.
So that's going to be
mechanism number three.
So now we have a space,
and we can measure fitness
along one axis-- ordinary
fitness-- and this is
rank space fitness, so
that's going to be P sub c.
There will always
be some individual
with the highest fitness.
And over here-- that might
not be P sub c, actually.
But there'll be some individual
with a maximal fitness,
and at any given
step in the selection
of the next population, there'll
be some individual that's
maximally diverse from all
of the individuals that
have been selected for the
next generation so far.
So what kind of
individual would you
like to pick for
the next generation?
Well, the one with
the highest fitness
rank and the one with the
highest diversity rank.
So what you'd really
like is you'd like
to have somebody right there.
And if you can't have
somebody right there,
if there's nobody right
there with a maximum fitness,
a maximum diversity
at the same time, then
maybe you can draw in
iso goodness lines,
like so, which are just how
far you are from that ideal.
So let's summarize.
You've got to pick
some individuals
for the next population.
When we pick the
first individual,
all we've got to
go on is how fit
the individual is,
because there's nobody
else in that next generation.
After the first
individual is selected,
then we can look at
our set of candidates,
and we can say which
candidate would
be more different from the
set of things we've already
selected than all the others.
That would get the highest
diversity rank and so on down
the candidate list.
So let's see how
that might work.
So we're going to use a
combination of fitness
rank and diversity rank.
And we'll just use
the simple one so far.
We'll use a small
step size, and we'll
let this run 100 generations
to see what happens.
Bingo.
It crawls right up there,
because it's trying
to keep itself spread out.
It uses that diversity
measurement to do that.
And at the same time,
it's seeking high fitness,
so that's why it's crawling up
to the upper right hand corner.
But in the end, that
diversity piece of it
is keeping the
things spread out.
So suppose you're a
shark or something.
You don't care about
diversity anymore,
And we could just turn that off.
Is that thing still running?
Go back to fitness rank-- bingo.
So there you are-- you're
stuck for 600 million years.
So let's see if this will
handle the moat problem.
See, our step size
is still small.
We'll just let this run.
So the diversity of P sub
is keeping it spread out,
pretty soon, bingo,
it's right in there.
It's across that big moat,
because it's got the crossover
mechanism that combines the
best of the x's and the best
of the y's.
So that seems to
work pretty well.
OK, so see, these are
some of the things
that you can think about
when you're thinking-- oh,
and of course,
we're a shark, we're
going to forget about diversity.
We'll change the
selection method
from fitness and diversity
rank to just diversity.
It collapses down on
to the highest hill.
Yeah, [? Feedball ?], what?
STUDENT: How does step size
translate into mutations?
PATRICK WINSTON: Oh,
just the-- question
is, how does step size
translate into mutation?
Instead of allowing myself
to take steps as big as 1/10,
I might allow myself to
take steps as big as 3/10,
according to some distribution.
So what to say about all this?
It's very seductive,
because it's nature, right?
The trouble is,
it's naive nature.
And as evolutionary theories
go, this is horrible.
This is naive.
So we'd like to use real
evolutionary theory,
except we don't have
real evolutionary theory.
Evolution is still a mystery.
Some things are pretty obvious.
You can breed fast race horses.
That works just like so.
The trouble is, we don't have
any real good idea about how
speciation takes place
and how a lot of evolution
works, because all these
chromosomes are connected
to their phenotype consequences
in very complicated ways
that nobody fully understands.
So there's a great deal
of magic in that genotype
to phenotype transition
that nobody really
understands very well.
So when people write
these programs that
are in the style of so
called genetic algorithm,
they're taking a photograph
of high school biology,
and they're spending a
long time building programs
based on that naive idea.
But that naive idea has lots
of places for intervention,
because look at all the
things you can screw around
with in that process of
going from one generation
to the next.
By the way, what
does mutation do?
It's basically hill
climbing, right?
It's producing a
little spread out,
and you're using the fitness
thing to climb the hill.
So you get a lot of choices
about how you handle that.
Then you get a lot of
choices about much crossover
you're doing.
What does crossover do?
It kind of combines
strong features
of multiple individuals
into one individual, maybe.
So you've got all
kinds of choices there.
And then your genotype to
phenotype translation--
how do you interpret
something like those zeroes
and ones as an if then rule,
for example, as something that's
in the hands of the designer?
Then you've got all the rest
of those things, all which
are left up to the designer.
So in the end, you
really have to ask--
when you see an impressive
demonstration, you have to say,
where does the credit lie?
And I mean that
pun intentionally,
because usually the people
who are claiming the credit
are lying about where
it's coming from.
But nevertheless,
let me give you
a couple of examples
of where this
has found actual, bona
fide practical application.
So when you look for
practical application,
you might say, well,
in what kind of problem
does a good front piece
combine with a good back piece
to produce a good thing overall?
And the answer is, when
you're making a plan.
So you might have a
problem in planning
that requires you to
take a series of steps.
And you might have two
plans, each of which
is a series of steps.
And you might combine these to
produce something new that's
the front half of one and
the back half of another.
So that's practical
application number one.
And that requires you to
interpret your chromosome
as an indicator of
the steps in the plan.
Another example is drawn
from a UROP project
a student did for
me some years ago.
He was a freshman.
He came to me and said, I
want to do a UROP project.
And I said, have
you taken 6.034?
And he said no.
And I said, go away.
And he said, I don't
want to go away.
I want to do a UROP project.
So I said, have
you read my book?
He said no.
I said, well, go away, then.
And he said, I don't
want to go away.
I want to do a UROP project.
So I said, I don't
have any UROP projects.
He said, that's OK.
I've got my own.
He's a finance
type guy, so he was
interested in whether he
could build a rule based
expert system that could predict
the winners at horse races.
So his rule based expert system
consisted of rules like this.
If x and y, then
some conclusion.
If l and m, then some
kind of conclusion.
And from these, he
would produce rules
like if x prime-- that's
a slightly mutated version
of the x antecedent-- and
m, then some conclusion.
So it's mutation and crossover.
And he was able to
produce a system that
seemed to work about as
well as the handicappers
in the newspaper.
So he started losing
money at a less fast rate.
He is now doing something in
the stock market, they say.
Doesn't talk so much
about it, though.
But an interesting application.
He came up with rules
like, if the sum
of the jockey's weight on
the post position is low,
that's good.
Well, that makes
sense in the end,
because the jockey's
weight is always
between 100 and 110 pounds,
and the post position is always
between 1 and 10 or
something, so they
were commensurate values.
And a low one is good, in fact.
Not bad.
But neither of those--
I mean, this is real stuff.
My company uses this sort of
stuff to do some planning work.
But neither of those is as
impressive as the demonstration
I'm about to show
you that involves
the evolution of creatures.
And these creatures consist of
block like objects, like so.
And they combine
like this, and so on.
And so how can
you make a feature
like that from a 0 1 chromosome?
Well, some of the
bits in the chromosome
are interpreted as
the number of objects.
Others are interpreted as
the sizes of the objects.
Others are interpreted
as the structure of how
the objects are articulated.
And still others are interpreted
as fixing the control algorithm
by which the creature operates.
So you see how
that roughly goes?
Would you like to see a
film of that in action?
Yes.
OK.
[? Solo ?] always
likes to see the films.
STUDENT: How would you measure
diversity in that graph?
PATRICK WINSTON:
The question is,
how do I measure the
diversity of the graph?
I did it the same way
I measured the fitness.
That is to say, I
calculated the distance--
the actual metric distance--
of all the candidates
for the next generation from
all of the candidates that
had already been selected.
I summed that up.
And from that sum,
I could rank them
according to how
different they were
from the individuals that were
already in the next generation.
It's like giving a rank,
and then from the rank,
I use that kind of calculation
to determine a fitness, ie,
a probability of
survival, and then
I just combine the two
kinds of probabilities.
STUDENT: So you always
kept-- every time
that you selected
something, you cached those.
And you kept everything
that you've ever
selected [INAUDIBLE].
PATRICK WINSTON: I'm always
using the individuals that
have already been
selected at every step,
so every step is
a little different
because it's working with
a new set of individuals
that have already been selected
for the next generation.
OK?
So let's see how this works.
So this is showing the evolution
of some swimming creatures.
And they're evolved according
to how well they can swim,
how fast they can go.
Some of them have quite exotic
mechanisms, and some of them
quite natural.
That looked like a sperm
cell floating away there.
Once you have these things
evolving, then of course,
you can get groups of
them to evolve together.
So you saw already some
that were evolving to swim.
These are evolving to
move around on the land.
It's interesting-- this was done
by Karl Sims, who at the time
was at a then thriving
company, Thinking Machines,
a fresh spinoff from MIT.
So he was using a vastly
parallel computer,
super powerful for its day,
thousands of processors,
to do this.
And it was a demonstration
of what you could
do with lots of computing.
In the early stages of
the experimentation,
though, its notion of physics
wasn't quite complete,
so some of the creatures evolved
to move by hitting themselves
in the chest and not knowing
about the conservation
of momentum.
I thought that was just great.
So here they are, out
doing some further--
So you look at these,
and you say, wow,
there must be something to this.
This is interesting.
These are complicated.
I think this is one of the ones
that was trained, initially,
to swim and then to
do land locomotion.
So eventually, Karl
got around to thinking
about how to make these
things evolve so that they
would compete for food.
That's the fastest,
I think, by the way,
of the land locomotors.
So that was training them
to-- evolving them to jump.
This is evolving them to
follow a little red dot.
Some of them have stumbled
upon quite exotic methods,
as you can see.
Seem to be flailing
around, but somehow
manage to-- sort of like
watching people take a quiz.
Making progress on it.
But now we're on to
the food competition.
So some of them go for
the food, and some of them
go to excluding their
opponent from the food,
not actually caring too much
about whether they get it.
That's sort of what children do.
There's a kind of
hockey player-- now,
here's two hockey players.
Watch this.
They're kind of-- one
succeeds-- it reminds me
a little bit of hockey,
rugby, something like that.
Sometimes, they just
get kind of confused,
go right after their opponent,
forgetting about the food.
Gives up.
I think these are the overall
winners in this elimination
contest.
I can't quite get there.
OK, so you look at that, and
you say, wow, that's cool.
Genetic algorithms
must be the way to go.
I remember the first
time I saw this film.
It was over in Kresge.
I was walking out of the
auditorium with Toma Poggio
And we looked at each other,
and we said the same thing
simultaneously.
We didn't say that genetic
algorithms were the way to go.
What we said was, wow, that
space is rich in solutions.
What we were amazed
by was not that simple
minded genetic algorithms
produced solutions
but that the space was
so rich with solutions
that almost any mechanism
that was looking around
in that space would find them.
But there's yet another
way of thinking about it,
and that is you could say, wow,
look at how smart Karl Sims is,
because Karl Sims is the
one who had his hands on all
the levers, all those choices.
And I kept emphasizing,
all those choices
that enabled him to trick
this thing, in some sense,
into stumbling across the
solutions in a space that
was guaranteed to be
rich with solutions.
So you have to ask-- so first
of all, diversity is good.
We noticed when we put diversity
into the genetic algorithm
calculations, we were much
better at finding solutions.
But the next gold star
idea that I'd really
like to have you go
away with is the idea
that you have to ask
where the credit lies.
Does it lie with the
ingenuity of the programmer
or with the value of
the algorithm itself?
In this case,
impressive as it is,
the credit lies in the
richness of the space
and in the intelligence
of the programmer,
not necessarily in the
idea of genetic algorithms.